- Well, we talked about musicians,
ah you know that maybe inspired everybody.
But what about like actors?
Do you have any actors
that inspired you Dave ?
- Christopher Walken.
- (Kelly) Oh my God I love.
I love this guy.
- (Dave) The best.
- (Kelly) Yeah
- (Dave) Christopher Walken.
I love Christopher Walken so much.
And there was once when we
were on Saturday night live and
he was hosting and he came
up before we were about to,
he was going to introduce us, you know,
as we're going to play,
he comes up and he goes, he said,
is the accent
on four or fighters?
And I knew how he was going to say it.
I was like the accents
on fighters actually.
So he got up there and he
goes, ladies and gentlemen,
four fighters.
- (Abigail)That's so amazing.
- (Kelly) I love that.
That's amazing.
I love it's funny though,
because as musicians though,
we're all musicians as well.
Like I am really inspired
by actors as well.
Like just as much sometimes as,
as the musicians I grew up listening to,
it's just people that are
creative and really like,
I don't know, inspire you.
I think it's a really broad
kind of creative field,
but let's talk about your music.
I didn't even know that you
or a musician until recently.
And I was like, what?
I was a you're like
talented. You do everything.
- Well thank you.
Thank you, um well
- And you call yourself sophomore.
Why come up with sophomore?
Why not go by Abigail ?
- You know, I really wish I had
a really cool story about it, but.
- Well, I usually, you don't need it.
You can just be a pilot.
You just want to be a pilot.
So it's not all deep. Apparently Abigail.
- I had a dream one night
where that was what I was.
That's what my name was as
I guess in life in general.
- I'm curious. So did you do it?
Cause I know a lot of people
like to come up with like more
of a stage name because they
want to separate it from like
you as the actor.
- Yeah, yeah I felt like if
it was under Abigail Breslin,
I just didn't want people
to be like, aahh Abigail
like she's trying to be a
singer song writer now. Like,
and yeah.
And I just kind of wanted them
to like it just because they
liked it and not because
they liked a movie I was in.
- Yeah I love that. I
love, let the hearts speak
I love that.
Well, you're doing a
song called witchcraft.
So later, so is it about witchcraft ?
What's it about ?
- Yes. So it's, my friend
came over, my friend Max, who,
who wrote it with me.
He just came over to my house
and I was like, oh, let's,
you know, write a song.
And we literally wrote
it in like 20 minutes.
And I just had this idea
about writing a song called
witchcraft because I'm a
very witchy person and.
- Wait what does that mean?
- Well, I have a lot of ivory tower.
- You do? My grandmother
did that apparently.
And I did not know that until recently.
- Oh really?
That's pretty cool. Yeah.
No, my whole family on my mom's side,
we come from kind of a
long line of witchy women.
- Wait what!
- (Abigail) Yeah.
- That's so cool.
We all have like different
kind of like, I'm a medium.
I like to say, like try
to meet, you know, I can.
- (Kelly) That's cool oh my God.
I don't want to I'm terrified.
Have you ever done anything
like that? Going to a sidekick ?
- You know,
I'm going to tell you something crazy.
When I was like 17 years old,
I decided that I was going to
ask the universe to become a
successful musician.
I'm not kidding. And I,
I had this little ritual in my carport.
Where I sat down and I
made this weird altar
with these different like
signs and then insignia
that meant and I lit candles.
And I literally prayed to the
universe to someday become a
successful musician.
- I, is that in your book?
Is that in your book?
You should have included that in the book.
- Yeah it's like.
- (Kelly) That's amazing.
- I don't know who I sold my soul to, but.
- But it worked.
- So you're witch too.